This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 1960s, the psychologist Elizabeth Kubler Ross was studying patients with terminal illnesses. She noticed a pattern as they came to terms with their mortality. The patients seemed to go through different psychological phases. Elizabeth Kubler Ross eventually classified these phases into what she called the five stages of grief, denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and acceptance. The five stages were intuitively appealing and offered people a way to understand a complex experience. Very quickly, the simplicity of this framework began to seep into popular culture. Books, TV shows, and later countless YouTube videos. Your mind is protecting you by completely denying the reality.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在20世纪60年代，心理学家伊丽莎白·库布勒-罗斯一直在研究绝症患者。她注意到患者在接受自己的死亡命运时呈现出一种规律。这些患者似乎会经历不同的心理阶段。伊丽莎白·库布勒-罗斯最终将这些阶段归纳为她所说的悲伤的五个阶段：否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁和接受。这五个阶段在直觉上很吸引人，为人们提供了一种理解复杂经历的方式。很快，这种简单框架的普及就开始渗透到大众文化中。书籍、电视节目，后来还有无数的 YouTube 视频。你的大脑正在通过完全否认现实来保护你。
Numbness may follow its nature's way of letting you deal only with your emotions that you're capable of handling. that you're capable of handling. As often happens, a system that was designed to be descriptive became prescriptive. The five stages translated into popular culture morphed into a model that told people they should expect to feel certain emotions and that their experience of grief would be a journey from one stage to the next. Finally, five is acceptance. It's the fifth stage and this is the end game here. And it is the result of all the stages of your grief. Over time, the five stage model of grief
麻木可能遵循其自然规律，让你只去处理那些你有能力应对的情绪。正如经常发生的那样，一个旨在进行描述的系统变成了规定性的。这五个阶段被翻译到大众文化中，演变成了一种模型，告诉人们他们应该预料到会感受到某些情绪，并且他们经历悲伤的过程将是从一个阶段到下一个阶段的旅程。最后，第五阶段是接受。这是第五阶段，也是这里的终局。它是你所有悲伤阶段的结果。随着时间的推移，五阶段悲伤模型
became so ingrained in people's minds that new insights based on rigorous research did not get as much airtime. For decades, the popular understanding of what we feel when we grieve was largely drawn from the five-stage model. Anyone who's ever been bereaved will know that people tell you about them, they expect you to go through them, and pretty quickly I became frustrated with them because I don't want to be told what I'm going to feel. I am desperate to know what I can do to help us all adapt to this terrible loss. Today we bring you the story of a researcher whose understanding of grief was transformed by a devastating experience in her own life. The surprisingly powerful
在人们的头脑中根深蒂固，以至于基于严谨研究的新见解没有得到那么多的关注。几十年来，大众对我们悲伤时感受的理解很大程度上都源于五阶段模型。任何经历过丧亲之痛的人都知道，人们会向你提起它们，他们期望你经历这些阶段，而我很快对它们感到沮丧，因为我不想被告知我将感受到什么。我迫切地想知道我能做些什么来帮助我们所有人适应这种可怕的损失。今天，我们为您带来一位研究人员的故事，她对悲伤的理解因她自己生活中的毁灭性经历而发生了转变。这种惊人强大的
technique she learned to cope with tragedy this week on Hidden Brain. Lucy Hone is a researcher at the University of Canterbury in New Zealand. In 2010, she was living near Christchurch when it was struck by a powerful earthquake. The disaster and a series of aftershocks killed 185 people and destroyed most of downtown Christchurch. Thousands of people lost their homes. Lucy had just returned from graduate school in the United States. She was about to embark on a PhD. Her area of study,
她学会应对悲剧的技术，本周尽在《隐藏的大脑》。露西·霍恩是新西兰坎特伯雷大学的研究员。2010年，她住在基督城附近，当时该市遭遇了一场强烈的地震。这场灾难和一系列余震夺去了185人的生命，摧毁了基督城的大部分市中心。数千人失去了家园。露西刚刚从美国的研究生院返回。她正准备开始攻读博士学位。她的研究领域是
resilience. Given the disaster unfolding around her, Lucy rolled up her sleeves and started applying what she had already learned to help the people around her. One day, during a powerful aftershock, Lucy was standing outside her home, which was perched on the cliffs overlooking the city. And I just stood there looking down on our village and I could see the children's school there and I could see them all lining up, obviously being looked after and counted. But what was so awful for me was that I could also see the cliffs on the other side of the village really close to them, less than a mile away from them, tumbling down in front of them.
韧性。鉴于周围发生的灾难，露西挽起袖子，开始运用她已经学到的知识来帮助身边的人。一天，在一次强烈的余震中，露西站在她位于俯瞰城市的悬崖边的家外面。我只是站在那里俯视我们的村庄，我能看到那里孩子们的学校，我能看到他们都在排队，显然得到了照顾和清点。但对我来说最可怕的是，我也能看到村庄另一侧离他们很近的悬崖，离他们不到一英里远，在他们面前坍塌。
So it was a pretty scary moment in my life. The Christchurch earthquakes lasted for more than a year. Residents lived in a constant state of anxiety, not knowing when the next tremor would strike. At one point, Lucy was giving a talk on resilience to survivors when a woman in the audience raised her hand and described a problem she was having. She just said to me, I'm startling all the time. I just am so jumpy every time someone crashes a sorspin lid. I seem to kind of jump in the air and my heart is pounding.
所以那是我生命中相当可怕的一个时刻。基督城的地震持续了一年多。居民们生活在持续的焦虑状态中，不知道下一次震动什么时候会袭来。有一次，露西正在向幸存者发表关于韧性的演讲，这时听众席上的一位女士举起手，描述了她遇到的一个问题。她只是对我说，我一直在受惊吓。每当有人把保温瓶盖摔出声，我都会变得非常神经质。我似乎会跳到空中，我的心在狂跳。
And you know, what do I do about that? And I said, firstly, does anyone else feel like that? And the whole room lifted up their hand. So I think it was, you know, a real moment of collective resonance where we all realized that we had exactly the same startle reaction from those ever present earthquakes. You just never knew whether you were safe and you never knew when the next one was going to come. So that kind of hyper-vigilance was pretty omnipresent. going to come so that kind of hyper-vigilance was pretty omnipresent. The problem was some of this hyper-vigilance, it was totally justified.
你知道，我该怎么办？我说，首先，还有其他人有这种感觉吗？整个房间的人都举起了手。所以我想，这是一个真正的集体共鸣时刻，我们都意识到，对于那些无处不在的地震，我们都有完全相同的惊跳反应。你永远不知道自己是否安全，也永远不知道下一次地震什么时候会来。所以那种高度警惕在当时可以说是无处不在的。问题是，其中一些高度警惕完全是合乎情理的。
Because we had 10,000 over 10,000 aftershocks and 5 or 6 really major events. One of those was on Boxing Day and I'd taken my two sons and a friend visiting from England over to one of the big malls to the Boxing Day sales and we were all just sitting there afterwards having something to eat in one of the cafes and suddenly the whole mall started shaking and so we got under the tables and you know all the cups of teas were being knocked over and but it really terrified us. And I remember locking eyes with my eldest son. And that was probably the moment that we realized
因为我们经历了一万次、超过一万次余震以及五六次真正的大地震。其中一次发生在节礼日，我带着两个儿子和一位从英国来访的朋友去了其中一个大型购物中心赶节礼日大促销，我们之后都坐在那里的一家咖啡馆里吃东西，突然整个商场开始晃动，所以我们钻到了桌子底下，你知道，所有的茶杯都被撞翻了，但它真的吓坏了我们。我记得和我的大儿子四目相对。那可能就是我们意识到
that these earthquakes weren't going to go away. That actually we were probably now in for a pretty rocky ride. So I would have fast forward a couple of years. In the summer of 2014, this is a couple of years after the earthquakes. I think you're still working on your PhD at this point. You organized a family beach vacation. It was several hours from your home and you were planning to go with two other families. You and your husband and two teenage sons drove together. I understand your daughter Abby went with another family. Yes, that's right. So my friend Sally and I had arranged a family, you know, get away on a long weekend in June. And at the last minute,
这些地震不会消失的时刻。事实上，我们现在可能要经历一段相当颠簸的旅程了。所以让我快进几年。在2014年夏天，这是地震发生几年后。我想你当时还在攻读博士学位。你组织了一次家庭海滩度假。它离你的家有几个小时的路程，你正计划和其他两个家庭一起去。你和你的丈夫以及两个十几岁的儿子一起开车前往。据我了解，你的女儿艾比和另一个家庭一起去了。是的，没错。所以我的朋友莎莉和我安排了一个家庭，你知道的，在六月份的一个长周末去度假。然后在最后一分钟，
Sally's daughter Ella, who was the same age as Abby, just 12 years old at the time, phoned up to say, hey, can Abby come with us in the car? You know, they were great girlfriends and always together. So we thought nothing of it and said, yeah, absolutely, you hop in with her and we dropped Abby off and went on our way and we had a sort of four-hour journey ahead of us. And they didn't turn up, you know, later when they should have done, but we didn't really think anything of it at the time. Lucy and her family went to a local restaurant and sat down to dinner.
莎莉的女儿埃拉（Ella）当时和艾比同龄，只有12岁，打电话来说：“嘿，艾比能和我们坐一车去吗？”你知道，她们是很好的女朋友，总是形影不离。所以我们没多想，就说：“好啊，当然行，你跟她一起上车吧。”我们把艾比放下就上路了，我们前面大概有四个小时的车程。他们当时并没有出现，你知道，比预定时间晚了，但我们当时并没有真正放在心上。露西和她的家人去了一家当地餐馆坐下来吃晚餐。
Abby still hadn't arrived, but they were not too worried. The family Abby was traveling with had probably just gotten stuck in traffic. And so we just carried on having dinner without them. And then the hotel owner came and said to us, there's a policeman on the phone for you and he'd like to speak to one of you. When Lucy's husband Trevor got on the phone, the police officer didn't say why he wanted to talk. He only said he needed to drive out to meet them. I think he said there's been an accident and I need to come out and talk with you in person.
艾比依然没有到达，但他们并不是很担心。艾比随行的那个家庭可能只是堵车了。于是我们没有他们也继续吃晚饭。然后酒店老板走过来对我们说，有一个警察在给你打电话，他想和你们中的一个人通话。当露西的丈夫特雷弗接起电话时，警官并没有说他为什么想通话。他只说他需要开车出来见他们。我想他说有了一起事故，我需要亲自出来跟你们谈谈。
That was the defining moment. That was the moment when I remember Trevor looking across at me and saying, he's coming to see us and he wouldn't say any more, but they don't bring you good news, do they? And so we hunkered down in the lodges office with the manager who we did kind of know through other families who knew her. And so that was reasonably comfortable being with her, but actually the whole experience, of course,
那是决定性的时刻。那一刻我记得特雷弗看着我说，他要来见我们，他没有再多说，但他们不会给你带来好消息，对吧？于是我们和经理一起缩在旅馆办公室里，我们确实通过认识她的其他家庭认识她。所以和她在一起算是相当舒适，但实际上整个经历，当然
was anything but comfortable. And I remember pacing the room. And possibly it was about a 20 minute wait. He come from the local police station that just isn't very local. So we had an agonizing wait. When the police officer finally arrived, he had an odd question about Abby's shoes.
一点也不舒适。我记得在房间里踱步。可能等了大约20分钟。他从当地警察局赶来，其实并不是非常近。所以我们经历了痛苦的等待。当警官终于到达时，他问了一个关于艾比鞋子的奇怪问题。
He asked me what she was wearing, and probably like any mother. I knew exactly what my dear daughter was wearing and so I told him. Abby was wearing black converse chucktailer high tops. And he said to me, in that case, I'm sorry to tell you that your daughter, that was your daughter in the accident. And, you know, I'm tragically have to tell you that she has died. I'm tragically have to tell you that she has died. And he also told us that Sally, my friend, had been killed and Sally's beautiful daughter Ella, who was such dear friends with our Abbey, had also died, so all three of them had been hit
他问我她穿的是什么，可能和任何母亲一样。我清楚地知道我亲爱的女儿穿的是什么，所以我告诉了他。艾比穿着黑色匡威高帮帆布鞋。他对我说，既然如此，我很遗憾地告诉您，您的女儿，那是您在事故中的女儿。而且，你知道，我悲痛地必须告诉您，她已经去世了。我悲痛地必须告诉您，她已经去世了。他还告诉我们，我的朋友莎莉遇难了，莎莉美丽的女儿埃拉——她是我们艾比的好朋友——也去世了，所以他们三个人都被一辆
by a car who drove through a stop sign and plowed into them. It's hard to even imagine what you were going through at this point, Lucy. This is literally every parent's worst nightmare, but this nightmare was actually happening to you. Did you have a sense of being able to process what was going on, were you in shock? I was definitely in shock. I think it is a bit of an outer body experience. You can almost observe
闯过停车标志并撞向他们的汽车撞倒了。露西，很难想象你当时正在经历什么。这简直是每个父母的噩梦，但这个噩梦真的降临到了你身上。你当时有能力处理正在发生的事情吗，你是在休克状态吗？我绝对处于休克状态。我认为这有点像灵魂出窍的体验。你几乎可以观察
yourself going through the process. I remember the physical sensations of feeling sick and sweating and having a droid drank so much water. I remember that and I remember pacing. Couldn't stay anywhere. You know, I remember getting on the floor, getting up, walking around. I just, you know, you don't know what to do in that moment. I remember calling my sister and not being able to get through to her, and then calling every member of her family and it turned out they were all together in a bar and they suddenly realized that something awful would happen because they'd all had these missed calls. And I remember the other people in the lodge and kind of feeling sorry for them thinking,
自己经历这个过程。我记得生病、出汗和喝了那么多水的身体感觉。我记得那些，我还记得踱步。无法在任何地方待下去。你知道，我记得倒在地板上，站起来，四处走动。我只是，你知道，你在那一刻不知道该做什么。我记得给我的姐姐打电话，却打不通，然后给她的每个家庭成员打电话，结果他们都在酒吧里，他们突然意识到发生了可怕的事情，因为他们都看到了这些未接来电。我还记得旅馆里的其他人，有点为他们感到难过，心想，
oh, this is such an awful thing for you to watch. So you have kind of odd, I think, odd thoughts. But actually what I remember Shunker most of all is this feeling that that was our new life story and that her death would be part of our life story for, you know, the remainder of our days. That night, the police drove Lucy and her family to a hospital in Christchurch. Where we then met my sister and her family, which was just a terrible moment, you know, you can imagine family collective grief, and we were asked to go and identify the body, and my dear son, Paddy, said to his dad, come on dad, we've got to go and do it. Just awful moments.
哦，对你们来说看着这一幕太可怕了。所以你会有一些奇怪的想法，我想。但实际上，森卡，我最记得的是这种感觉，即那是我们的新生活故事，而她的死将成为我们生活故事的一部分，你知道，在我们余下的日子里。那天晚上，警察开车把露西和她的家人送到基督城的一家医院。我们在那里遇到了我姐姐和她的家人，那真是一个糟糕的时刻，你可以想象家庭集体的悲伤，我们被要求去认尸，我亲爱的儿子帕迪对他的爸爸说，爸爸，来吧，我们得去办这事。真是糟糕的时刻。
We went home at 5 or 6am and all just walked back into the house and sat there in disbelief. I do remember in those first hours and days to be honest, feeling like I was on autopilot and that people were kind of moving me around, standing behind me, kind of pointing my shoulders in the direction I had to go, you know, it was just staggering really numb. And you just, in disbelief, I think that is the thing, isn't it, that when it comes out of the blue, your world has been smashed apart, nothing makes sense.
我们在早上5点或6点回家，全都走进房子里，难以置信地坐在那里。我确实记得在最初的几个小时和几天里，说实话，感觉自己像在自动驾驶，人们在某种程度上推着我走，站在我身后，把我的肩膀指向我必须去的方向，你知道，真的是惊愕得麻木了。而你只是，难以置信，我想这就是那种感觉，对吧，当事情突如其来时，你的世界被粉碎了，一切都说不通。
And you're just struggling and grappling to get through each hour. And I honestly, I remember there's awful grief, sweats and not sleeping, sleeping, it was awful. I understand that at one point soon after Abbi's death, a couple of grief counselors came to your home. Do you remember what they told you? I do.
你只是在挣扎，努力熬过每一个小时。老实说，我记得那种可怕的悲伤，盗汗，无法入睡，睡觉，这太可怕了。据我了解，在艾比去世后不久的某个时候，有几位悲伤辅导员来到了你的家。你还记得他们对你说了什么吗？我记得。
We had a few people come and give us well-meaning advice. And really what I've got stands out for me is that I remember them saying to me, you're going to need to write five years of your life off to this grief. You know, you're really not going to be able to function for the next five years. And that we were now prime candidates for divorce, family, estrangement, and mental illness. And honestly, I remember thinking, wow, I thought my life was already truly terrible. I can't believe that people are kind of dumping all this on us as well. And I was horrified. So I remember someone talking to me about the fact that they'd lost a brother who had died.
有几个人来给我们一些好意的建议。实际上对我触动最大、最清晰的是，我记得他们对我说，你得把生活中五年的时间都用来承受这份悲伤。你知道，在接下来的五年里，你真的无法正常生活。而且我们现在是离婚、家庭疏远和精神疾病的头号候选人。老实说，我记得当时想，哇，我以为我的生活已经够糟糕了。我简直不敢相信人们还把这一切都倾卸在我们身上。我感到震惊。所以我记得有人跟我谈起过他们失去了一个兄弟的事。
And then he said, to be honest, I don't really speak to my other brother any longer, you know, his death tore our family apart. And I remember thinking, okay, right, that's something else. I'm going to have to watch out for. The friends and councillors obviously meant well, but after they left, Lucy felt worse. It wasn't just that they were telling her that her life was terrible. They also seemed to be telling her that there was nothing she could do about it. When we come back, Lucy started to wonder if that was true. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
然后他说，说实话，我不再跟我的另一个兄弟说话了，你知道，他的死撕裂了我们的家庭。我记得当时想，好吧，对，那是我必须小心的另一件事。朋友和顾问显然是出于好意，但他们离开后，露西感觉更糟了。不仅仅是他们告诉她生活很糟糕。他们似乎还告诉她，她对此无能为力。当我们回来时，露西开始怀疑这是真的吗。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是森卡·韦丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Lucy Hone is a public health researcher at the University of Canopyry in New Zealand. She studies resilience. In the summer of 2014, Lucy experienced every parent's greatest nightmare. Her 12-year-old daughter was killed in a car crash. Before the accident, Lucy had been helping survivors of the Christ Judge earthquakes. Suddenly, she needed help herself. Lucy, you've described a moment soon after the accident when you found yourself standing in your bedroom asking yourself a question and the question was can I go on? Can you describe that moment to me? Yes, it was my darkest bleakest moment. I think where I
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是森卡·韦丹塔姆。露西·霍恩是新西兰坎特伯雷大学的公共卫生研究员。她研究韧性。2014年夏天，露西经历了每个父母最大的噩梦。她12岁的女儿在车祸中丧生。事故发生前，露西一直在帮助基督城地震的幸存者。突然之间，她自己也需要帮助了。露西，你曾描述过事故发生后不久的一个时刻，当时你发现自己站在卧室里问自己一个问题，那个问题是：我能坚持下去吗？你能向我描述一下那个时刻吗？是的，那是我最黑暗、最凄凉的时刻。我想我在那里
did have where I did have a sense that it all felt just too hard. Every day it felt like we were climbing a mountain. Instead of ever, we never got to the top. Every day you'd be put down to the bottom and have to start the whole thing again. It was exhausting and I lost hope and I'm a pretty hopeful person and so I think that is a moment that really stands out for me. So something that many people don't realize is that grief isn't just in the mind as you say it's physically exhausting. It certainly is, honestly, physically exhausting. I did a lot of sleeping.
确实会有那种感觉，觉得一切都太难了。每天都像是在爬山。我们永远到不了山顶，反而每天都会被丢回山底，然后不得不重新开始这一切。这太累了，我失去了希望，而我其实是一个挺有希望的人，所以我觉得这是一个对我来说非常深刻的时刻。很多人没有意识到的是，正如你所说，悲伤不仅存在于脑海中，它在身体上也是极度消耗精力的。确实如此，老实说，真的非常耗费体力。我当时做了大量的睡眠。
And of course, sleep gives you a temporary break as well from the thinking, because it is dusk, goes round and round in your head. And I was lucky that I could sleep, and that our boys were of an age where I could go to bed at any time of day if it was all too much. And I knew because of my training, the importance of sleep as well. I understand that you had conversations at this time with your husband where you were running through what if scenarios regarding Abbey.
当然，睡眠也让你从思考中获得暂时的喘息，因为黄昏时分，思绪会在你的脑海里转来转去。我很幸运，自己还能入睡，而且我们的两个男孩也到了一个年龄，如果这一切实在让人难以承受，我随时都可以上床睡觉。因为我的专业背景，我也深知睡眠的重要性。我听说你当时和你的丈夫有过这样的对话，你们在脑海中反复推演关于艾比的“如果……会怎样”的情景。
Do you remember what they were about Lucy? And we once sat down on the rocks we live by the beach and we sat there and yes having those kind of what if we hadn't arranged that we can go away and what if you know we hadn't let her in the car but then we also said to each other, she didn't suffer, we didn't have to sit like so many parents at her bedside for weeks and months and watch the live train out of her. We took some comfort from the fact that she died instantly and wouldn't have known what was happening to her.
露西，你还记得它们是关于什么的吗？我们曾经坐在海边的岩石上，坐在那里，是的，那种“如果我们没有安排那场旅行会怎么样”，还有“如果我们当初不让她上车会怎么样”。但随后我们也对彼此说，她没有遭受痛苦，我们不必像许多父母那样，在她的病床边守上几周几个月，看着生命从她身上一点点流逝。我们得到了一点安慰，因为她瞬间离去，不会知道当时正发生了什么。
And so we were, yeah, in that sense, we were just trying to help each other focus on the bits that weren't so terrible. At the same time, I think this is really revealing about people's grief journeys in general, which is that very often when grief strikes a family, the people whom you would normally turn to for help are also suffering. And that can really make it difficult to find your way out because everyone around you is also being weighed down by this thing.
所以在某种意义上，我们只是在努力帮助彼此把注意力集中在那些不那么可怕的事情上。与此同时，我认为这非常深刻地揭示了人们普遍的悲伤历程：当悲伤降临到一个家庭时，你通常会向其寻求帮助的人，往往也同样在承受痛苦。这确实会让你很难找到出路，因为你身边的每个人也都在被这件事情压得喘不过气来。
Well, it's so true, Shankaran, and everybody grieves differently, you know? And my mother had died when I was 30 and Trevor lost his father when he was 12. So we had both experienced grief before, but we were very aware that, you know, we have two, 14 and 15-year-old beautiful boys who were obviously processing it in a different way to their parents, and then we had all Abby's friends. We live in a small family community, and so we had all of them. And we weren't just one family, but two families. And so there was a real sense of collective grief. You know, they lost two girls from the local primary
确实如此，尚卡尔，每个人悲伤的方式都不同，你知道的？我母亲在我30岁时去世了，特雷弗在12岁时失去了父亲。所以我们以前都经历过悲伤，但我们非常清楚，我们有两个14岁和15岁可爱的男孩，他们的悲伤处理方式显然与父母不同，然后我们还有艾比所有的朋友。我们生活在一个小型的家庭社区里，所以我们拥有他们所有人。我们不仅仅是一个家庭，而是两个家庭。因此有一种强烈的集体悲伤感。你知道，他们失去了当地小学的两个女孩
and one of the mums, and particularly so soon after the earthquakes. You see that grief had a way of sneaking up on you. You call these grief ambushes. What do you mean by that term? Honestly, that awful aspect of grief is that you just can't control the emotions. And in the least likely moments, they seem to absolutely take hold of you. And so whether it was sitting at the traffic lights or once I write about how I went to the supermarket, which because it had fallen down in the earthquakes, we didn't have a local supermarket for sometime, you know, five or six years. So it wasn't until after Abbey died that they re-opened
其中一位女孩的母亲，特别是在地震发生后不久。你会发现悲伤会以一种悄然无息的方式袭来。你把这称为“悲伤伏击”。你这个词是什么意思？老实说，悲伤最糟糕的一个方面就是你根本无法控制情绪。在最意想不到的时刻，它们似乎完全控制了你。所以，无论是坐在红绿灯前，还是有一次我写到自己去超市——因为超市在地震中倒塌了，我们好一段时间（五六年）没有当地的超市。直到艾比去世后，他们才重新开业
the local supermarket and I swam in there thinking fabulous, it's back, you know, how good is this? And I just got to the aisle that had her favorite snacks in it and just stood there and dissolved. And it just took me back to so many times when her little kindergarten was across the road and we'd come there after Kindi. And she'd buy her favorite bits and we were always together. And I just stood there and thought, ah, seriously, this is literally that kind of brief ambush that overwhelms you and we're almost powerless to do anything about it.
那家当地的超市，我兴高采烈地走了进去，心想太棒了，它又开业了，你知道的，这有多好？结果我刚走到摆着她最喜欢的零食的那个过道，就站在那里崩溃了。这一下子把我的思绪拉回了无数个过去的时刻：那时她的小幼儿园就在马路对面，我们从幼儿园出来后就会来到这里。她会买她最喜欢的零食，我们总是形影不离。我站在那里想，啊，天哪，这简直就是那种将你淹没的悲伤伏击，我们几乎无能为力。
And it was OK for me me because I was in a quiet supermarket aisle at the time, but you know, when it happens at work, that's just, it's a really tough, challenging aspect of grief. So the grief counselor is another's told you that the next five years of your life are going to be consumed by grief that you were prime candidates for divorce and a strange men mental illness. You also heard about the five stages of grief. What was the conventional wisdom about the five stages of grief, Lucy?
对我来说还好，因为当时我在一个安静的超市过道里，但你知道，当它发生在工作场所时，那就真的、真的是悲伤中一个非常严峻且具有挑战性的方面。因此，悲伤咨询师和其他人曾告诉你们，你们生活的接下来的五年将被悲伤吞噬，你们是离婚和精神疾病的高危候选人。你还听说了悲伤的五个阶段。关于悲伤的五个阶段，传统的普遍看法是什么，露西？
So I think to be fair, like most people, I was kind of aware of those five stages. Like most people, I could probably name three of them, but when people started telling me about them and boy, anyone who's ever been bereaved will know that people tell you about them, they expect you to go through them. And pretty quickly I became frustrated with them because I didn't feel anger and animosity towards the driver. I knew that that was a terrible mistake, but he didn't do it intentionally. And I wasn't in denial, you know, from the very first moment, as I've said, I remember thinking, okay, this is my job now, you know, my mission is to survive this. And so they didn't kind of fit with my experience, but the other aspect
所以我觉得公平地说，像大多数人一样，我其实也知道那五个阶段。像大多数人一样，我大概能说出其中三个的名字。但当人们开始向我提起它们时——天哪，任何经历过丧亲之痛的人都会知道，人们会向你提起它们，并期望你经历这些。很快我就对它们感到沮丧，因为我对那个司机并没有感到愤怒和敌意。我知道那是一个可怕的错误，但他不是故意的。而且我也没有处于否认状态，你知道的，从最初的那一刻起，正如我所说，我记得自己想的是：好的，这就是我现在的任务，我的使命是熬过这一关。所以它们并不太符合我的经历，但另一个方面
that quickly frustrated me about the five stages is that I just found them too passive. You know, it's reasonably helpful to be told that these, you might feel, you know, depression and acceptance or anger and denial and all of these different things. But actually, it was like, I don't want to be told what I'm going to feel. I am desperate to know what I can do to help us all adapt to this terrible loss. I'm struck by the fact that at a certain point in your journey of grief over Abbey's death, you were thinking like a researcher or starting to ask yourself whether you yourself could be an almost a research subject that you're studying yourself, you're observing yourself,
很快让我对这五个阶段感到沮丧的是，我发现它们太被动了。你知道的，有人告诉你可能会经历抑郁、接受，或是愤怒、否认以及所有这些不同的情绪，这在一定程度上是有帮助的。但实际上，我的感受是：我不想被人告知我将会有什么感受，我极其迫切地想知道我能做些什么来帮助我们所有人去适应这场可怕的丧亲之痛。我印象深刻的是，在你经历艾比去世的悲伤旅程的某个特定阶段，你的思考方式就像一个研究人员，或者开始问自己，你是否可以成为一个几乎是研究对象的人——你在研究自己，你在观察自己，
you're thinking of your own experience, not just as a person going through the experience, but like a scientist. Did you have a moment of epiphany when you realized in some ways that you could become your own research subject on this topic? I think I did, I think it's fair to say that, yes, was kind of an epiphany, ah-ha moment. And it is also, you know, who I am. I am a researcher, and I'm a mum and a wife. And so you're always, we all wear multiple hats, don't we? It's just that mine happened to be that I was experiencing this devastating loss and curious about my experiences simultaneously.
你不仅仅把自己当作一个经历这种痛苦的人，而是像个科学家一样思考自己的经历。当你意识到在某些方面你可以成为这个课题自己的研究对象时，你是否有过顿悟的时刻？我想我是有的，我觉得可以这样说，是的，那确实是一种顿悟，“啊哈”的时刻。这也是我是谁的一部分。我是一名研究人员，同时我也位母亲和妻子。所以你总是——我们每个人都扮演着多重角色，不是吗？只不过我恰好正在经历这种毁灭性的丧亲之痛，同时又对自己的经历充满好奇。
And that was the kind of ah-ha moment that I was doing this internally, kind of observing my loss and my reaction to it. And then I thought, well, what I'm really curious about is we have all these tools from resilient psychology, which have been shown to help people cope with potentially traumatic events. Well, how useful are they when they are brought to the context of bereavement? And so that's been the question that I've been really exploring ever since I've been died. Pondering this question gave her the space to analyse how her own mind was responding to grief. When she noticed something about how she was
这就是那种“啊哈”时刻，我在内部进行这种观察，观察我的悲伤以及我对它的反应。然后我想，我真正好奇的是：我们拥有来自韧性心理学的各种工具，这些工具已被证明可以帮助人们应对潜在的创伤性事件。那么，当把它们带到丧亲之痛的语境中时，它们有多大用处呢？这就是自我女儿去世以来我一直在真正探索的问题。思考这个问题为她提供了一个空间，去分析她自己的内心是如何对悲伤做出反应的。当她注意到关于自己如何
coping, she reserved judgment about what it meant. When she engaged in what if scenarios, what if she hadn't allowed Abby to drive with the other family, what if she hadn't planned a beach vacation, she noticed how these thoughts made her feel. She paid attention to how she felt after getting exercise or a good night's sleep. In other words, she started behaving like a scientist. She eventually discovered there were things that made her feel better and things that made her feel worse. She came up with a series of techniques that gave her a measure of control over her grief. I distinctly remember standing in the kitchen thinking, seriously Lucy, choose life, not death,
应对的一些情况时，她对这意味着什么保持了克制，不予评判。当她陷入“如果……会怎样”的情景时——比如如果当初没有让艾比跟另一个家庭一起开车会怎么样，如果当初没有计划海滩度假会怎么样——她会去注意这些想法带给她的感受。她会留意自己通过锻炼或获得充足睡眠后的感受。换句话说，她开始像科学家一样行事。她最终发现有些事情让她感觉好一些，有些事情让她感觉更糟。她想出了一系列的技术，让她在一定程度上对自己的悲伤有了控制权。我清晰地记得自己站在厨房里想：说真的，露西，选择生活，而不是死亡，
don't lose what you have to what you have lost. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Lucy Hohn is a public health researcher at the University of Canterbury. After her 12-year-old daughter was killed in a traffic crash, Lucy tracked her own bereavement process closely. She realized that she herself did not follow the five stages of grief. She also realized that we are wrong when we think grief is only something that happens to us.
不要让失去夺走你所拥有的。欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。露西·霍恩是坎特伯雷大学的一名公共健康研究员。在她12岁的女儿在一次车祸中丧生后，露西密切追踪了自己的丧亲过程。她意识到自己并没有经历悲伤的五个阶段。她还意识到，当我们认为悲伤只是降临在我们身上的事情时，我们错了。
While it's true that grieving people do not feel they have much control over their emotions, there were things she could do to change the way she felt. They were active choices she could make. These choices did not erase her grief. That was neither possible nor healthy. But they did allow her to feel like she could manage it. The first step was to realize there was a difference between her reaction to grief and her response to it. Yes, so your grief reaction, you have very little control over, and that is all those physical symptoms that occur when we are bereaved. And, you know, for me, that was that aching right in my solar plexus and that the grief sweats, those awful nighttime sweats, and then the storage roller coaster of emotions.
虽然悲伤的人确实觉得他们对自己的情绪没有什么控制力，但她可以通过做一些事情来改变自己的感受。她可以做出积极的选择。这些选择并没有抹去她的悲伤。那既不可能也不健康。但它们确实让她觉得自己能够掌控悲伤。第一步是意识到，她对悲伤的“反应”和对悲伤的“回应”之间是有区别的。是的，所以对于悲伤的反应，你的控制力非常小，那都是我们在痛失亲人时发生的各种生理症状。你知道，对我来说，那就是太阳神经丛深处的隐痛，还有悲伤带来的盗汗，那些可怕的夜间盗汗，以及随后情感的过山车。
So it's really hard to control those and we call that grief reaction. But we do also have the grief response, which is about how we choose to respond to the grief. And that is about the ways of thinking and acting and the micro choices we make all day long which can really help our harm our grief. And so, you know, while grief reaction we have little control, grief response is pervaded with choice. As Lucy started to analyse her own grief like a scientist, she stumbled on the work of Columbia University researcher George Bonanna. Well, certainly George Bonanna's work is really comforting and what he discovered was that actually most people get through grief on their own without needing any kind of medication or clinical intervention. And so this kind of really gave me hope and the other great researchers in this field are Straub and Schut, whose oscillation
所以控制这些真的很难，我们称之为悲伤反应。但我们确实也有悲伤回应，这关乎我们选择如何应对悲伤。这关乎我们一整天都在做出的思维方式、行动以及微小的选择，这些选择可能会真正帮助或加重我们的悲伤。所以，你知道的，虽然对于悲伤反应我们几乎无法控制，但悲伤回应却充满了选择。当露西像科学家一样开始分析自己的悲伤时，她无意中发现了哥伦比亚大学研究员乔治·博南诺的工作。嗯，当然，乔治·博南诺的工作真的让人感到安慰，他发现其实大多数人都能独自度过悲伤，而不需要任何药物或临床干预。这确实给了我希望，该领域的另一位伟大研究员是斯特罗布和舒特，他们的振荡
theory I came across, which is a different kind of model of grief that says that we need to approach our grief and then it's okay to withdraw and take a break from grief and that that's not avoidance and denial, but actually a really healthy way to grieve. You're talking about the researchers, Margaret, Struber and Hank should describe for me again what they meant by the storm oscillation, because you found both yourself going through this, but also in some ways deciding to sort of pursue this yourself. Yes, I think it made sense to me. So their theory of oscillation is that we oscillate between approaching our grief and then taking a break from it, but we also oscillate between attending to these two different types of grief. One is loss oriented and the other is
理论我偶然遇到了，这是一种不同类型的悲伤模型，它表明我们需要去面对悲伤，然后暂时退后并从悲伤中休息一下也是可以的，这并不是回避和否认，而实际上是一种非常健康的悲伤方式。你谈到了研究人员玛格丽特·斯特罗布和汉克·舒特，请再为我描述一下他们所说的“悲伤振荡”是什么意思，因为你不仅发现自己正在经历这个过程，而且在某种程度上决定亲自去深入探究它。是的，我觉得这对我很有意义。所以他们的振荡理论是，我们在走近悲伤和从悲伤中抽离休息之间来回振荡，但我们也在关注这两种不同类型的悲伤之间来回振荡。一种是面向失去的，而另一种是
restoration oriented, meaning that you kind of fluctuate between coping with the loss, the actual for me, you know, Abbey and how much I missed her. And then the restoration bit is about, and who am I now, and how will I learn to live without her and her place in the family? And how am I going to get back to work and go to the supermarket and face my friends? So you kind of ebb and flow between these two processes. And it's a real kind of dynamic process. What resonated for me was that we needed to take breaks from our grieving process,
面向重建的，这意味着你会在应对失去——对我来说，实际上面对的是艾比以及我多么想念她——之间产生波动。而重建部分则是关于：我现在是谁，我将如何学会没有她以及她在家庭中的位置该如何继续生活？我将如何重返工作岗位、去超市并面对我的朋友？所以你会在这两个过程之间起伏跌宕。这确实是一种动态的过程。对我产生共鸣的是，我们需要从悲伤的过程中抽离出来休息，
and actually that's where positive emotion can come into. When Lucy first confronted Abby's death, grief felt like an impossible mountain looming before her. When she was told she was a prime candidate for divorce or mental illness, that mountain grew larger. But when she started looking at the scientific evidence, she discovered cause for hope. While a small minority of people do get stuck in grief, the majority recover and regain
而这实际上正是积极情绪可以产生的地方。当露西第一次面对艾比的死时，悲伤就像一座无法逾越的大山隐约出现在她面前。当有人告诉她是离婚或精神疾病的高危候选人时，那座山变得更高了。但当她开始审视科学证据时，她发现了带来希望的理由。虽然只有极少数人会陷入悲伤无法自拔，但大多数人都会恢复并重获健康的心理功能水平。
healthy levels of psychological functioning. When Lucy chose to spend time away from her grief, this wasn't denial. Her brain was doing the perfectly healthy thing of oscillating between attending to grief and attending to recovery. Lucy also arrived at a third insight. I know from resilience psychology that it's really important to choose where you focus your attention. And so I absolutely had this voice in my head that would be aware if I was bargaining,
当露西选择花时间远离悲伤时，这并不是否认。她的大脑在做一件非常健康的事情：在关注悲伤和关注康复之间来回振荡。露西还得到了第三个洞察。我从韧性心理学中了解到，选择将注意力集中在哪里真的非常重要。所以我脑海里绝对有这样一个声音，如果我在讨价还价，它就会察觉到。
if I started to do that, what if I hadn't booked that weekend the way, what if we had just left, they just left 10 minutes later that day. And then I'd think to myself, you're only allowed to have two what ifs. So once I'd done one, you know, what if we hadn't booked, I actually, I booked the holiday, the weekend away. So what if I hadn't booked it?
如果我开始这样做：如果我们当初没有预订那个周末的旅行会怎么样，如果我们只是晚离开10分钟会怎么样。然后我会对自己说：你只被允许有两次“假设”的机会。所以一旦我做了一次，你知道的，“如果我们没有预订”——其实是我预订了假期，那个周末的旅行。所以“如果我没有预订会怎么样”？
And what if we hadn't allowed her into the car that day? And then I'd go to do another one, and I'd think, nope, that's your limit. Go and distract yourself because any more what ifs are going to be harming you and you need to survive this. And so I would distract myself by phoning somebody else or doing something that really demanded my attention.
“如果我们那天没有让她上车会怎么样”？然后当我打算进行下一次假设时，我会想：不，这就是你的极限。去转移注意力吧，因为再有更多的假设会对你造成伤害，你必须熬过这一关。所以我就会通过给别人打电话或做一些真正需要我注意力的事情来转移自己的注意力。
This was part of a larger idea borrowed from cognitive behavioral therapy. As thoughts went through her mind, she started to ask herself a simple question, is this thought good for me or bad for me? An important fork in the road came when Lucy and her husband were asked to attend the trial of the driver who had run the stop sign and T-bone the car in which Abby was riding. Lucy asked herself, would going to the trial be good for me or bad for me? Grief is full of choices and so when we were invited to go to the trial, I used a strategy that encourages you to ask yourself, is doing that, going to help me or harm me in my quest to survive this loss? And so Trevor and I
这是借鉴自认知行为疗法的更宏大理念的一部分。当各种想法在脑海中闪过时，她开始问自己一个简单的问题：这个想法对我是好是坏？一个重要的十字路口出现在露西和她的丈夫被要求参加那个闯了停车牌并撞击了艾比所乘车辆侧面的司机的审判时。露西问自己：去参加审判对我是好是坏？悲伤充满了选择，所以当我们被邀请去参加审判时，我使用了一种策略，它鼓励你问自己：这样做，在我努力熬过这场丧亲之痛的过程中，是会帮助我还是会伤害我？所以特雷弗和我
both agreed that we didn't want to go to the trial, that actually that wasn't going to help us. I just didn't need to be standing in the same room as the driver at that time. I needed to focus my energy and attention elsewhere. And that was on the boys. So in fact, we went instead to their school, just that day to meet with the teachers and just kind of check in with them because they'd just been back at school in about three weeks, I think. And that felt like a much better use of my time. And I'm distinctly know that what I appreciate it was that I was kind of putting myself in the driver's seat
都同意我们不想去参加审判，事实上那对我们没有帮助。我当时不需要和那个司机站在同一个房间里。我需要把我的精力 and 注意力集中在其他地方。那就是放在男孩们身上。事实上，我们那天去了他们的学校，去见见老师，了解一下他们的近况，因为他们大约在三周前刚回到学校。我觉得这才是对我时间的更好利用。我清楚地知道，我所感激的是，我把自己放在了驾驶座上，
and taking back a bit of control. So in some ways, I think what I hear you saying is that when people are experiencing grief, partly, what we almost expect them to do is we expect them to follow scripts. And sometimes you provide scripts to them and say, here's what you're supposed to feel, and here's what comes next, and here's what comes before this, and here's what you're supposed to do after this.
重新夺回了一点控制权。所以在某种程度上，我想我听到你所说的是，当人们经历悲伤时，在某种程度上，我们几乎期望他们做的事情就是按照剧本走。有时你向他们提供剧本并说：这就是你应该感受到的，接下来是这个，这个之前是那个，在这之后你应该做的是这个。
And in some ways, by taking back that narrative, you can start to make choices that in some ways craft your own journey. And it may be that the choice that you make is different than the choice that your husband makes, but it's important that each of you exercises the agency to make the choice that in some ways is the best fit for your mental makeup and your psychological well-being. Yeah, that's completely it. We all grieve differently. Grief is as individual as your fingerprint.
在某种程度上，通过夺回那个叙事权，你可以开始做出选择，在某些方面打造你自己的旅程。你做出的选择可能与你丈夫做出的选择不同，但重要的是，你们每个人都行使自主权，做出最适合你们心理结构和心理健康的抉择。是的，完全是这样。我们每个人悲伤的方式都不同。悲伤就像你的指纹一样独一无二。
There's actually very little evidence that says that we go through those five stages, they have been perpetuated because they're a tidy model and health practitioners and people like to, that they are drawn to the fact that when people are grieving and it's such a torrid time, that if they can just give them a tidy five stage model, then maybe that, you know, makes them feel better and it's easier for the health practitioners to kind of give this model. But actually, it's then maybe that, you know, makes them feel better and it's easier for the health practitioners to kind of give this model. But actually, it's not like that. It's messy and untidy and in our work, people rarely say that they go through those stages. I'm wondering if there were other choices you found yourself having to make where you could ask yourself the question, is this going to be good for me or is this going to be bad for me? Absolutely. It became my kind of go-to strategy and I would,
事实上，几乎没有什么证据表明我们会经历那五个阶段，它们之所以流传下来，是因为它们是一个整洁的模型，而健康从业者和人们喜欢它们，他们被这样一个事实所吸引：当人们处于悲伤之中、经历如此痛苦的时期时，如果能给他们提供一个整洁的五个阶段模型，那么也许这（你知道的）能让他们感觉好受一些，而且健康从业者也更容易给出这个模型。但实际上，事情并非如此。它是混乱的、毫无条理的，在我们的工作中，人们很少说他们经历过那些阶段。我想知道，你是否发现自己还得做出其他选择，在这些选择中你可以问自己这个问题：这对我来说是好是坏？绝对的。这成了我的首选策略，我会……
I'd often find myself, of course, you know, I'm weak-willed like everybody and I'd find myself trawling through Instagram later at night, looking at pictures of Abby and noticing the comments that her friends have put on there. And I do that for a few minutes and then think seriously Lucy, you know, is this helping or is it harming you be kind to yourself, put your phone away and go to bed. And I so often did find those things, you know, looking at photos, even just hanging out with her friends, as I say, we're a pretty small community, so I would bump into her friends. And sometimes that would be good. And other times, I'd think, no, that's actually not what you need right now, that's not going to be good for you. So just walk back out of the supermarket and come back later on whatever it was, but it was definitely my kind of practical question
我常常发现自己，当然了，你知道，我和大家一样意志薄弱，深夜会在Instagram上翻来翻去，看艾比的照片，留意她朋友们在上面留下的评论。然后我看了几分钟，就会严肃地想，露西，你知道的，这到底是对你有帮助还是在伤害你？对自己好一点，把手机收起来去睡觉。我经常发现这些行为，你知道，看照片，甚至只是和她的朋友们在一起——正如我所说，我们是个相当小的社区，所以我经常会偶遇她的朋友。有时那感觉不错，但有时我会想，不，这其实不是你现在需要的，这不会对你有好处。所以只要走出超市，晚点再来，不论具体是什么事，但这绝对是我的一种实际问题
that enabled me to find my own pathway through grief. It's worth pointing out that I think that what you did is not easy to do. It really is easy to get angry. It does feel natural to engage in what ifs, these are human reactions. And I want to flag that while making conscious choices about what to focus on does make sense,
它让我能够找到自己穿越悲伤的途径。值得指出的是，我认为你所做的事情并不容易做到。生气确实很容易。陷入“如果当初”的想法确实很自然，这些都是人类的反应。我想指出的是，虽然对应该关注的事情做出有意识的选择确实很有意义，
that doesn't mean that it's always easy to do. No, and I would totally agree with that. And I always make that point of saying to people, you know, this isn't easy, but it is possible. And I think it comes down to, for me, my motivation for survival was huge, to, for me, my motivation for survival was huge because we had lived through every parent's worst nightmare and I felt like the stakes were pretty high and that almost made that easier to stick to the two what ifs rule because I felt like if
但这并不意味着这总是很容易做到。是的，我完全同意这一点。我总是向人们强调这一点，你知道的，这并不容易，但它是可能的。我认为归根结底，对我来说，求生的动力是巨大的，对我来说，求生的动力是巨大的，因为我们经历了每个父母最噩梦般的经历，我觉得赌注相当高，这几乎使得坚持“不作假设”的规则变得更容易了，因为我觉得如果
I didn't, the grief could completely consume me. And so that's not saying that I'm in denial because I certainly did grieve and we did, you know, I'm all for experiencing all kinds of emotions and I didn't want to shut them out, but I definitely wanted to find my way and while oowing in things that are beyond my control was not helpful to me. And as I say, I felt like the fight was on for survival. Lucy thought back to her days as a graduate student studying resilience at the University of Pennsylvania. At one point, her professors worked with the US military to develop a resilience training program for a million soldiers.
我做不到，悲伤就会彻底吞噬我。所以这并不是说我在否认，因为我确实经历了悲伤，我们确实，你知道的，我完全支持体验各种各样的情绪，我不想把它们关在门外，但我绝对想找到自己的出路，沉溺于超出我控制的事情对我毫无帮助。而且正如我所说，我觉得生存之战已经打响。露西回想起她作为宾夕法尼亚大学研究韧性的研究生的日子。有一次，她的教授们与美军合作，为一百万士兵开发了一项韧性培训计划。
That program was based on the same underlying idea. Pay attention to where you pay attention. There was very much that kind of cognitive focus that you need to be aware of the way your thoughts and actions are combining and really question whether the ways you are thinking and acting are working for you or working against you. And so they did lots of that sort of took positive psychology, this field of being strengths-based and put that into a package so that they could train the drill sergeants who then in turn could train all of the rest of the army. And I love the phrase that they use in this training which was hunt the good stuff.
该计划基于相同的核心理念。关注你所关注的地方。这里有很强的认知焦点，你需要意识到你的思想和行为是如何结合的，并真正质疑你的思考和行事方式是对你有帮助还是在阻碍你。所以他们做了很多这样的事情，把积极心理学——这个基于优势的领域——打包成一个方案，以便他们能够培训钻木教官，然后教官再反过来培训其余所有的军队。我喜欢他们在培训中使用的一个短语，叫做“寻找美好事物”。
And I love that idea because you're speaking to your audience in a language they can understand, but it's the same idea that's being preached in cognitive behavioural therapy. Absolutely. So they actually created the hashtag htgs hunt the good stuff. And actually somebody after Abbey died gave us a poster that said accept the good. And I think these two phrases accept the good and hunt the good stuff. Speak to the fact that language is really important here, that what we're talking about is that we want to encourage people to tune into what is still good in their world, despite everything that's happened.
我喜欢这个想法，因为你在用你的听众能听懂的语言与他们对话，但这与认知行为疗法中倡导的理念是一样的。绝对如此。所以他们实际上创造了一个话题标签#htgs（寻找美好事物）。事实上，在艾比去世后，有人送给我们一张海报，上面写着“接受美好”。我认为这两个短语——“接受美好”和“寻找美好事物”——说明了语言在这里真的很重要，我们想要讨论的是，我们希望鼓励人们去调整自己，去发现他们世界中依然美好的事物，尽管发生了一切。
But we're also encouraging them to find language that fits with them. So for me, you know, being told to count my blessings or ask to do random acts of kindness. It's just not language that sits well with me, but having this great big pink fluro poster in our kitchen that says, except the good, seemed to do the same job. So I think it's important for people to find the language that works for them. Lucy also realised that language could help her. She was not just a grieving mom and researcher, but a writer, and she found that putting her experience on the page gave her both perspective
但我们也鼓励他们寻找适合自己的语言。所以对现阶段的我来说，你知道的，别人告诉我数算自己的福气，或是去做随机的善举，这些语言并不适合我。但是，在我们的厨房里挂着一张巨大的粉红色荧光海报，上面写着“接受美好”，它似乎起到了同样的作用。因此，我认为人们找到适合自己的语言是很重要的。露西也意识到语言可以帮助她。她不仅是一位悲伤的母亲和研究人员，还是一位作家，她发现把自己的经历写在纸上既能给她带来视角
and comfort. Her writing eventually became a book titled, Resilion Grieving. One of the ideas she explored in the book had to do with how many people deal with grief by asking, why me? Lucy came to see that this was counterproductive. She once gave a TED talk to illustrate the idea. She asked people in the audience to do something for her. If you're comfortable, please stand up.
又能带来安慰。她的写作最终成了一本名为《有韧性的悲伤》的书。她在书中探讨的观点之一与许多人如何通过问“为什么是我？”来应对悲伤有关。露西逐渐认识到这是适得其反的。她曾做过一次TED演讲来阐释这个观点。她请听众为她做一件事。如果你觉得舒适，请站起来。
If any of the following have happened to you, whether it is dementia or whether it is a physical impairment or whether it is cancer or divorce or redundancy. And actually, of course, within 30 seconds we've got the whole room standing. And the point is to make people realize that adversity doesn't discriminate.
如果以下任何情况曾发生在你身上，无论是痴呆症、身体残疾、癌症、离婚还是失业。事实上，当然，在30秒内，整个房间的人都站起来了。重点是让人们意识到逆境是不分对象的。
You know, as much as we don't want this to be true, terrible things happen to us all. And knowing that makes it so important to understand how you react in tough times, and to understand the ways of thinking and acting that can help you navigate your darker days. You say that resilient people understand that bad things happen, that suffering is a part of life, and that knowing this keeps them from feeling like victims. Can you expand on this idea, Lucy? What do you mean by that? Yes, I think understanding that everybody suffers in parts of life, you know, that actually
你知道的，尽管我们多么不希望这是真的，可怕的事情都会降临到我们每个人头上。了解这一点，对于理解你在艰难时期的反应至关重要，也能帮助你理解那些能够帮你度过黑暗日期的思维和行事方式。你说过，有韧性的人明白坏事会发生，苦难是生活的一部分，了解这一点能使他们免于觉得自己是受害者。你能详细谈谈这个想法吗，露西？你这话是什么意思？是的，我认为理解每个人在生活中的某些部分都在经受苦难，你知道，实际上
very often daily we struggle and suffer and that is absolutely part of the universal existence. Stopped you from feeling singled out and discriminated against when something goes wrong, but critically it also stopped you from beating yourself up when things go wrong. And so when we live in a, you know, a era of perfectionism, it's so important for people to understand that, you know, a era of perfectionism, it's so important for people to understand that, you know, we all stuff up and do things wrong all day long and that doesn't mean we need to be punished, it doesn't mean we're useless, it just means we're human. And this idea actually goes back a really long ways, Lucy. Hidden Brain is a show that's
很多时候我们每天都在挣扎和受苦，这绝对是普遍存在的一部分。这能阻止你在出错时觉得自己被单独挑出来或受到歧视，但至关重要的是，它也能阻止你在事情出错时自我苛责。因此，当我们生活在一个完美主义的时代时，让人们理解这一点是如此重要，你知道，一个完美主义的时代，让人们理解这一点是如此重要，你知道，我们整天都在搞砸事情、做错事，但这并不意味着我们需要受到惩罚，并不意味着我们一无是处，这只意味着我们是人类。而这个想法其实由来已久，露西。“隐藏的大脑”是一个
primarily about science, but I can't help but make the connection with the origins of Buddhism, you know, according to the story, the prince of Dhartha is supposed to have seen, you know, people age and suffer and die, and as a result of seeing that, you know, internalize the very idea that you're talking about, which is that suffering is inevitable. And so, in some ways, the lessons that you're talking about here might be in some ways confirmed are backed up by modern empirical scientific tools, but there really are really age-old ideas. I couldn't agree more. And even this element of stoicism in there as well, isn't it? Yeah, we did an episode about stoicism with a philosopher William Irvin and he had this great line, do what you can with what you have where you are.
主要关于科学的节目，但我忍不住将其与佛教的起源联系起来，你知道的，根据传说，悉达多王子本应看到人们老去、受苦并死去，由于看到了这些，你知道的，内化了你所谈论的那个理念，即苦难是不可避免的。因此，从某种程度上说，你在这里谈论的教训，可能在某种程度上得到了现代实证科学工具的证实或支持，但它们确实是非常古老的思想。我不能更赞同了。甚至其中也包含着斯多葛学派的成分，不是吗？是的，我们曾与哲学家威廉·欧文制作了一期关于斯多葛学派的节目，他有一句很棒的话：用你所有的，在你所在的地方，尽你所能。
And it's the same idea, which is we can only do what we can do, but if we pay attention to what we can do, that's not nothing. Yeah, absolutely. And in all of our work, we always encourage people to focus on the things that matter and the things that they can control. And, you know, that's very similar. As Lucy looked for ways to apply these insights in her day-to-day life, she started to seek opportunities to find serenity, pride, and awe.
这也是同样的理念，也就是我们只能做我们能做的事，但如果我们关注我们能做的事情，那并非无所作为。是的，绝对是这样。在我们所有的工作中，我们总是鼓励人们专注于那些重要的事情以及他们能够控制的事情。你知道的，这非常相似。当露西寻找在日常生活中应用这些见解的方法时，她开始寻找能获得宁静、自豪和敬畏感的机会。
Yes, I do remember taking myself off into the hills to do a walk one day and standing there in the really kind of big mountainous kind of landscape of New Zealand and that made me feel better because I kind of felt like when you're in that and surrounded by majesty on that kind of grand scale it makes you feel smaller and I found that really helpful and somebody recently in one of our courses was just saying to me, I've done exactly the same thing by visiting a cathedral or a park, so getting out there into nature,
是的，我确实记得有一天我独自去山里散步，站在新西兰那种真正浩瀚的群山风景中，这让我感觉好多了，因为我某种程度上觉得，当你处于那种环境中，被那种宏大尺度的壮丽所环绕时，你会觉得自己变得更渺小了，我发现这真的很有帮助。最近我们课程中的某个人刚刚对我说，他也通过参观大教堂或公园做了完全相同的事情，所以走到大自然中去，
I also used to attend my boys rugby matches to go and be inspired and feel proud of them. And I used to listen to Desert Island discs, which is a BBC radio podcast, because that kind of checkered life journey that people go on would give me hope. So just different little ways of bringing those positive emotions back into my everyday life. Is it possible that some people resist doing those things because they almost feel guilty about doing them? They might worry, are other people going to say, you know, she's just lost her daughter?
我以前也经常去观看我男孩们的橄榄球比赛，去寻找灵感并为他们感到骄傲。我以前经常听BBC广播播客《荒岛唱片》，因为人们经历的那种曲折的人生旅程会给我带来希望。所以只是用各种不同的小方法把这些积极的情绪带回我的日常生活中。有没有可能某些人会抵触做这些事情，因为他们做这些事情时几乎会感到内疚？他们可能会担心，其他人会说，你看，她刚刚失去了女儿？
What is she doing at a restaurant? Or what is she doing watching a movie? That again, we are compelled to follow the scripts presented to us about how we're supposed to grieve and deal with Lars and trauma. deal with last and trauma. Exactly. That is what people say and experience. That they feel judged and feel guilty for experiencing any form of positive emotions, for laughing with friends or wanting to go out
她怎么在餐厅里？或者她怎么在看电影？这再次说明，我们被迫去遵循那些关于我们应该如何悲伤以及如何处理失去与创伤的固有剧本。处理失去与创伤。完全正确。这就是人们所说和经历的。他们因为体验到任何形式的积极情绪、因为与朋友欢笑或想要出门
and see a movie or just be out, you know, enjoying themselves. Isn't it a shame that so much of what is kind of out there and expected of grief is that you just have to be miserable for a long time. And if you're experiencing positive experiences, there's something wrong with you when actually we know that that is so far from the truth. So your work has attracted a lot of interest Lucy. And obviously there are people who are deeply moved by your story and your insights about healthy grieving. But some people might hear you saying
看电影或者仅仅是出门，你知道的，享受生活，而感到被评判和内疚。不是很遗憾吗，那些普遍存在且对悲伤的期待大多是让你在很长一段时间里都必须痛苦不堪。如果你正在经历积极的体验，那就是你身上出了问题，而实际上我们知道这与事实相去甚远。所以你的工作吸引了很多人关注，露西。很明显，有些人被你的故事以及你对健康悲伤的见解深深打动。但有些人可能会听到你说
that you want people who are at the lowest points in their lives to pull themselves up by their bootstraps, that grieving people need to be responsible for their own emotional recovery. Is that an accurate representation of your work? Oh, I certainly hope not. No, I think I really do make a very deliberate point in resilient grieving to say to people,
你希望处于生活最低谷的人靠自己的力量振作起来，那些处于悲伤中的人需要为自己的情绪恢复负责。这是对你工作的准确描述吗？哦，我当然希望不是。不，我认为我在《有韧性的悲伤》中非常刻意地向人们指出，
never am I trying to put more pressure on the bereaved. Wow, you know, that would be furtherest from my intention. All of our work is created for people who come to us saying thank you for validating my desire to be an active participant in my own grief journey. And so we know that so many people now are looking for ways to support them through that adaptation to loss. And so we're not forcing people, and we always say to people, here, actually, these are all of the theoretically sound and scientifically
我绝不是在给悲伤的人施加更多的压力。哇，你知道的，那将最不符合我的初衷。我们所有的工作都是为那些来到我们这里并说“谢谢你认可我渴望成为自己悲伤旅程中积极参与者的愿望”的人而创建的。因此，我们知道现在有很多人正在寻找能够支持他们度过适应丧亲之痛阶段的方法。所以我们并没有强迫人们，我们总是对人们说，这里实际上是我们遇到的所有理论上合理且有科学依据的策略。
backed strategies that we've come across. Try some of these out for yourself. See what works for you. Be your own personal experiment and find the grief journey that works for you. So I think that giving people a prescription for hope, I think, is the number one aim of our work. You lost your daughter Lucy in 2014, and you've written about how it's a mistake
自己尝试一下其中一些。看看什么对你有用。做你自己的个人实验，找到适合你的悲伤之旅。所以我认为给人们提供一张希望的处方，我认为是我们工作的首要目标。露西，你在2014年失去了女儿，你曾写过关于认为时间能缩小悲伤是一个错误的文章，
to think that time shrinks grief, but time does do something else. Can you tell me your insight about the circles around your grief? Yes, so this came from a local grief counselor, and her theory is that the briefs often think that their grief or their toll that their grief will shrink over time. But yet what really happens is that your grief stays the same and your world, your life,
但时间确实做了别的事情。你能告诉我你对围绕着你悲伤的那些圈子的见解吗？是的，这是从一位当地的悲伤咨询师那里听来的，她的理论是，悲伤的人常常认为他们的悲伤或悲伤带来的沉重感会随着时间而缩小。但实际发生的事情是，你的悲伤保持不变，而你的世界、你的生活，
grows around it. You know, seven years we are on now from Abbey's death and I can notice how our world has grown beyond her, you know, as much as I'd love to have her with us. There are new experiences and new people in our world who weren't around when she was here. And so I can see that life literally has grown around her and her loss. And she will always be in my heart, all of our hearts. And we carry her forward. We'll never forget her. But life grows and goes on. And as long as she's with us and we have her legacy then I don't want to say that that's okay because it's not but I guess it's good enough.
在它周围成长。自从艾比去世以来，我们已经走过了七个年头，我能注意到我们的世界是如何超越她而生长的，尽管我很希望能让她和我们在一起。我们的世界里有了新的经历和新的人，而她在这里时他们并不在。所以我可以看到生活确实围绕着她和她的失去生长了。她将永远在我的心中，在我们所有人的心中。我们带着她继续前行。我们永远不会忘记她。但生活在成长，生活在继续。只要她和我们在一起，我们拥有她的精神遗产，那么我不想说这没关系，因为这并不是，但我想这已经足够好了。
Lucy Hone is a public health researcher and practitioner in New Zealand. She's the author of Resilient Grieving, finding strength and embracing life after a loss that changes everything. Lucy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me, Shankar, and for all you in your listeners' time. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
露西·霍恩是新西兰的一名公共卫生研究员和实践者。她是《有韧性的悲伤：在改变一切的失去之后寻找力量并拥抱生活》一书的作者。露西，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔，也感谢你和听众们的时间。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。
Our unsung hero today is Lisa Turner. Lisa is a content strategist at Facebook. We were recently having some problems making tweaks to the Hidden Brain Facebook page. Lisa came up with a solution even though our request was outside her area of responsibilities. She also followed up several times to make sure the problem was solved. responsibilities. She also followed up several times to make sure the problem was solved. We are so grateful for your help Lisa. If you like hidden brain, be sure to check out our sister podcast. It's called My Unsung Hero. Each episode is about a time when an unsung hero came to the aid of someone in need. I promise it will renew your faith in humanity. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们今天的无名英雄是丽莎·特纳。丽莎是脸书的一名内容策略师。我们最近在对“隐藏的大脑”脸书主页进行微调时遇到了一些问题。丽莎想出了一个解决方案，尽管我们的请求超出了她的职责范围。她还跟进了好几次，以确保问题得到解决。职责范围。她还跟进了好几次，以确保问题得到解决。我们非常感谢你的帮助，丽莎。如果你喜欢“隐藏的大脑”，一定要去听听我们的姊妹播客。它叫“我的无名英雄”。每一集都讲述了一个无名英雄伸出援手帮助处于困境中的人的故事。我保证它会重塑你对人性的信念。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。